while some higher level researchers
specialized guards and containment
experts at the scp foundation have fixed
anomalous projects tailored to their
very particular set of skills for many
lower level operatives including junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded d-classes every day is
showing up spinning the wheel of
misfortune and finding out how you might
die today will you be hacked to pieces
by a murder monster pulled into a portal
turned into a doll
eaten alive made into a living nest by
bugs stretched out and broken drowned
examinated set on fire beaten to death
by a volley of anomalous tomatoes
because you decided to drop a
cringe-worthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course chief among these is the
legendary scp-999
also known by its adorable moniker the
tickle monster we don't need to get into
too much detail in describing this
gelatinous ray of sunshine his anomalous
delightfulness has made him somewhat of
a celebrity compared to the murderer's
row of terrifying entities and monsters
around him the researcher assigned to
him today was troubled having seen one
of his favorite co-workers devoured by
scp-682 the day before getting assigned
to feeding and checking on scp-999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of m ms in hand
the creature cooed perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be alright for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
eminem's into its eager mouth radiating
good vibes the whole time what an asset
what a gift and to think this adorable
little goober was prophesied to someday
save the world that much seemed almost
funny but he was certainly more than
capable of saving the life of someone
who hadn't felt the warmth of internal
sunshine in quite some time and for that
much the researcher was profoundly
grateful he left 999's chamber that day
with a renewed sense of hope for the
future that maybe just maybe they might
be able to pull through to make a
difference to push this crazy ball of
rock we call our home in the right
direction maybe someday the sun would
rise on a perfect world who would have
thought that a strange sunrise could
change everything emergency sirens went
off across the globe but in every case
they were drowned out by a terrible
endless chorus of screams but below all
that you'll hear another gut-wrenching
sound a low but pervasive sizzling like
an egg on a hot pan as billions of human
beings started to change their states of
matter the scp foundation had fought off
and contained so many seemingly
impossible threats from interdimensional
horrors like the hanged sealed and
scarlet kings to nightmarish mass
killers like scp-106
the old man
scp-096 the shy guy and
scp-682 the hard-to-destroy reptile in
their many battles against the anomalous
they developed the incredible
methodologies and exceedingly advanced
technology but what good would any of it
do when the very center of our solar
system decided in an instant that rather
being the linchpin of our delicate
cradle of life it would instead be the
horrible instrument of all of our
demises this awful hypothetical was
answered upon the emergence of
scp-001 a terrible day also known as
when daybreaks in the snap of one's
fingers half the world was plunged into
terror and death rays of stark red light
swept through the streets people lucky
enough to be in the shade or inside
buildings with a view to the outside saw
the people in the streets seize up and
begin to shriek in terrible pain their
skin sagged and their bones liquefied
their bodies dropped down to the ground
and coalesced into gurgling wretching
puddles the color of melted flesh those
who saw this abomination happening would
never forget it it would stay with them
for the rest of their lives it would
endure like a stain on their retinas an
after image burned into the plasma of an
old tv screen but here's a slight
consolation for most of the human race
the rest of their lives wouldn't be that
long the sudden insanity taking over the
world caused the scp foundation to do
something drastic step out of the
shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that humanity could live on in
the dark thankfully the very concept of
the day gave them one advantage
while one side of the earth was
effectively doomed the second the
process began the other side had a 12
hour head start before the sun turned
its terrible eye to them sirens went off
in the middle of the night waking people
up groggy rubbing the sleep from their
eyes every television and radio an
internet-enabled device in their home
was playing the same message direct from
the scp foundation which now had
effectively commandeered the entire us
government along with the rest of the
world it gave them directions to the
nearest foundation containment site and
told them that if they didn't
immediately comply and find their way to
safety they would experience a terrible
death by sunrise and if you're at all
familiar with human beings you've
probably already predicted that they
didn't just calmly wrap themselves up
make their way to their cars and form an
orderly line to the various foundation
containment sites located around them it
was in fact total pandemonium as the
solar clock ticked down slowly marking
off the seconds that anyone outside had
left to live the only human beings with
a meaningful head start began to go
insane in a number of varied and
interesting ways some who took the
situation seriously and acknowledged
that the sun was indeed going to wipe
out most of humanity simply cracked
under the pressure there were those who
went into totally catatonic states
rocking back and forth in the corner and
refusing to respond to any stimuli some
became erratic and violent with
unpredictable behavior that harmed
themselves and others after all what was
the point in acting normally anymore
when the complete crumbling of human
civilization was imminent and their only
hope was some shadowy organization
they'd never heard of some not heeding
the warning seriously enough and
prompted by greed and opportunism tried
to take advantage of the situation
financially some smashed windows of
local stores and looted or broke into
the homes of neighbors who had already
fled in hopes of prelowing their
property others were a little more
creative setting up short-term
everything must-go nighttime fire sales
for their brands of essential oils newer
tropics and nutraceuticals claiming all
of them had the power to ward off or
cure the new effects of the sun others
completely denied the possibility that
any of this was real and claimed that
the messages from the so-called scp
foundation were actually just a front to
take away their freedoms and trap them
in underground government camps they
staunchly refused to follow any of the
safety guidelines that the scp
foundation put out claiming if you try
to take away my first amendment rats
you're gonna take away my second
amendment rights while riding around in
their pickup trucks and suvs blasting
kid rocks don't tell me how to live at
ear splitting volumes naturally they had
all melted into screeching puddles of
liquid flesh by sunrise some were not
victims of their own bizarre choices but
were doomed by the sudden terrible fear
and panic of the circumstances
themselves the highways were gridlocked
cars stuck as far as the eye could see
so many had rushed to escape during the
initial wave that means of transport
soon became choke points like clogged
arteries in a dying man people do
irrational things when they're scared
riots broke out in the streets fighting
killing burning everyone hoping for some
means of meager control over a situation
that had long been out of any of their
hands some were too far away with not
enough time to close the distance what
could they really do but just sit around
and wait to die the hours marched on as
the earth made its slow turn towards the
sun leaving one decimated half in
darkness and the other a sitting duck
for its terrible effects hundreds of
thousands had made their way to the
containment sites and safely gotten
inside but still so many millions were
left outside it was a slaughterhouse one
great big global meat grinder and every
moment that passed the handle turned and
any humans left outside got just that
little bit closer to the grinding
gnashing gears below site 19 being the
largest containment site on the
foundation books also became humanity's
only bastion it was the great hope of
escape from the horrors going on outside
the foundation had figured out so many
ways of counteracting deadly anomalous
forces before given enough time and
enough personnel surely they could
figure out a solution to even this this
was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors those who were melted by the
sudden hostile sun weren't dead they
were very much alive in fact but they'd
been changed in both body and mind what
had once been humans now became terrible
beasts half-melted gelatinous nightmares
that coagulated into even bigger beasts
they got into their head that they were
grateful for the transformation that
they had been liberated from their old
forms in the old world they were
something so much more now and they
wanted everyone else to join them in
their liberation survivors outside the
foundation containment sites were
systematically hunted by these great
masses of altered flesh even though
smart enough to cover every inch of
their bodies with clothes to protect
from the sun to only move at night to
carry weapons were dragged out by meaty
tendrils from their refuge in the
basements and the lightless hearts of
buildings dragged into the searing gaze
of the sun to melt to change to coalesce
into something greater it was the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their manpower and
advanced weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
holed up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help
scp-999 the foundation was at war with
the sun and its terrible disciples and
contrary to many people's beliefs it
takes more than men equipment and
bullets to win a war 999 provided the
essential element that brought it all
together morale
hope the will to go on even when it
seemed like all could be lost after a
long day of battling the fleshy
abominations at the gates foundation
guards mobile task force members and
even civilian volunteers were drained
and traumatized by the horrors that
they'd seen once a day was over 999
would move among the ranks cuddling up
to them warding off the despair that was
easy to set in during the downswing of a
terrible apocalypse like this without
his presence there would be no hope of
fighting that good fight so many of them
would have given up walked into the sun
and joined the monstrous force they were
fighting after all they seemed happy
enough and it would certainly be easier
999 had become once again an
indispensable asset to the scp
foundation the solar betrayal may not
have been the scarlet king's doing well
as far as our current intel suggests
anyway but he was playing a crucial part
in saving the world exactly as predicted
999 didn't fully understand what was
going on outside sometimes why there
seemed to be fewer people as the weeks
went on and why the people there seemed
so sad all the time whenever he wasn't
helping them but he was more than happy
to help whatever the case many of the
humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class cots which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in dark times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering the long
dark corridors of site 19
he saw a different kind of crying it was
a woman with an unfamiliar face probably
one of the rare new refugees bawling her
eyes out to a foundation senior
researcher and an accompanying guard
with an assault rifle hot fat tears were
rolling down her dirty cheeks her
shaking hands clasped in prayer she was
begging the researcher and the guard to
let her go outside she said that her son
was still out there hiding away in the
back room of a bank where she used to
work they got separated she needed to go
back and find him sadly the researcher
and the guard told her that this was out
of the question official orders stated
that anyone outside the base at this
time was to be considered lost letting
her go out there to find her son would
essentially be condemning her to death
no human could go out there safely but
of course
scp-999 isn't by any definition a human
what knight fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 999 was
indeed an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the scp foundation might try to
stop it and when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and through
the broken streets there were no bodies
of course it seemed even the dead could
be revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
miracle but the broken down world
outside site 19 undeniably reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking and shattering to
themselves in a hundred different dead
voices 999 had been cross-tested with
and still those monsters frightened him
he decided it would be best to stay away
from them and make sure that they never
saw him out of here eventually 999
reached the town similarly dilapidated
and broken down in the months since the
world as we had all known it disappeared
in a ray of terrible sunshine more great
gibbering blobs of flesh patrolled the
streets looking for converts to
integrate into their biomass 999 could
only hope it wasn't already too late for
the little boy 999 discreetly slithered
from building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside they could feel the sadness and
the fear radiating off of him as it was
the creature's natural instinct to help
the needy and to use those signals like
a homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hit an inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
dried 999 cooed and chirped pleasantly
until the little boy was laughing again
but this momentary joy was soon
interrupted a great heaving weight
dragged itself down the hall outside
both 999 and the boy could sense its
monstrous presence as it got closer they
could hear all those chattering voices
those poisonous whispers when it passed
the door they heard it speaking its
voice practically vibrating with the hum
of malicious lunacy turn pretty flowers
turn towards the sun
feel it on your face
feel yourself change
loose and
become one with our army of one it must
be so lonely to be you
little flower
walk into the sun and be us
and the boy remained silent in the broom
closet for hours as the great shape
patrolled the bank outside searching for
converts for victims at times it seemed
too frightening to even breathe fearing
that would be enough to make the monster
detect them it felt like an eternity
until the monster eventually did slope
off and leave them in the comforting
quiet and darkness of the closet now
they might be free 999 could escort the
boy safely back to the containment site
and into the arms of his terrified
mother but when they opened the door
they saw a terrible sight light in the
distance pouring through the windows in
the glass double doors it wouldn't be
safe to go out that way upon seeing this
and putting together what it meant the
boy began to cry he couldn't take
another night in the closet it was all
going to wither from here until 999 had
a wonderful idea hours later when the
foundation guards manned the turrets at
the entrance of site-19 waiting for the
inevitable onslaught of the melted flesh
creatures they tensed up seeing a
blobbing gelatinous form slithering
towards them in the distance the guards
who'd learned the hard way from too many
lost men that it was better to be safe
than sorry drew a bead on the distant
shape and prepared to fire when suddenly
their superior race to hand and said
wait hold fire
is that 999 and it was they all stared
in astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
in amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own opacity 999
had given the boy safe passage through
the sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tearful reunion between
mother and child and a brief flash of
hope in this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to bask of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way and for a lot of people
scp-999 really was saving the world or
what was left of it anyway oh and of
course if scp-999 had won your hearts
just like it went ours you'd be pleased
to know that you can purchase your own
adorable high quality scp-999 plushie at
scpswag.com check the link in the
description to get your own trust us
having a 999 to cuddle really does make
any apocalypse a whole lot easier now go
check out
scp-001 when daybreaks and scp-999
tickle monster versus the most evil scps
for more of the two incredibly
contrasting anomalies from today's
episode